when I was a child I was about eight
years old and I went to climb on a house
that was under construction in our
neighborhood so I stepped up to the edge
and I fell and the Falls seemed to take
a very long time so then I was looking
down at the ground watching the red
brick floor come toward me and once I
hit the ground then I went unconscious
but it got me interested in the question
of how we perceive time when I grew up
that I became a neuroscientist what I
realized was we all come into the world
with this idea that time is just a river
that's flowing forward in one direction
at a fixed speed but what we know is
that it it can be different in your head
and in my head because it's somehow a
psychological construct time in other
words your brain is locked in silence
and darkness inside the vault of your
skull and it's job is to figure out
what's happening outside but it has to
do a lot of editing tricks your vision
and your hearing process signals at
different speeds and yet when you see
something like a balloon pop or somebody
clapping their hands it appears as
though the sight in the sound are
synchronized and what that means is the
brain has to be collecting all the
information before it puts together a
final story and serves that up to your
conscious perception it's like there's a
buffer where it looks for other signals
coming up the pipeline and as a result
it means that we're all living a little
bit in the past what we think is
happening right now has actually already
transpired some time ago probably in the
ballpark of about half a second ago in
the lab if I show you a photograph for
half a second on the screen and then I
show you that same photograph again for
half a second and then again and again
and again
and now I show you a different
photograph for the same amount of time
it will seem as though the new
photograph the oddball stays on the
screen for much longer time essentially
when the brain sees something that's
novel it has to burn more energy to
represent it because it wasn't expecting
that this feeling that things are going
in slow motion is a trick of memory in
other words when you're in an emergency
situation a part of the brain called the
amygdala comes online this is your
emergency control center it lays down
memories on what amounts to a secondary
memory track these are very dense
memories and you're noticing everything
around you and writing it all down so
when the brain reads that back out
there's such a density of memory there
that the brain's only conclusion is that
must have taken a long time and I think
this offers an explanation for why
people think that time seems to speed up
as they grow older and it's because when
you're a child everything's new to you
you're figuring out the rules of the
world you're writing down a lot of
memory and so when you look back at the
end of a year you have a lot of memory
of what you've learned but when you're
much older and you look back at the end
of the year you're probably doing
approximately the same stuff you've been
doing for the X number of previous years
and so it seems like the year just went
by and flat
really the way to feel as though you've
lived longer is to seek novelty so you
can start with something simple like
putting your wristwatch on your other
hand or brushing your teeth with your
other hand something this simple just
forces the brain into a new mode where
it can't predict exactly what's going to
happen but instead has to be engaged and
what that means is when you go to bed at
nighttime you have a lot of footage to
draw upon and it feels like your life is
lasting longer thanks for watching don't
forget to subscribe and click the bail
to receive notifications for new videos
see you again soon